hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everybody that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones video this week
lots of questions about the direwolves
and like a couple curious warding
questions about working in two White
Walkers and dragging the sub so I tried
to add that to the list I did see a
little confusion about when I said
George R Martin confirmed that benjin is
not cold hands so if you didn't see this
in my last video like it was it was
shown really quickly but it's a
manuscript from his editor asking if
benjin has cold hands and this know is
what Martin wrote in response so
negatory on Benjen cold hands but
careful for spoilers from the shows as
we get into questions so here we go
first question Danni asks sir pounce
will join I'm areas Wolf Pack and help
lead with her
so you're very clearly joking about sir
pounce but I wanted to use your question
to talk about the super pack so just
doing a headcount of the dire wolves
right now the only ones that are dead
are gray Wynn that's Rob's dire wolf and
lady Sansa's dire wolf although sophie
Turner and real-life adopted the dog
that they use for that so she actually
owns lady from the show now in real life
but Nymeria specifically lots of people
asking about her she's still totally
alive but remember during season one
when arya told her to run away after she
bit Joffrey they were on their way to
King's Landing so they were down closer
to the Riverlands so as of right now in
the books and on the show Nymeria has
just been running around collecting
wolves regular wolves she's kind of like
a super alpha so instead of a normal
wolf pack she has what George R Martin
has called a super pack meaning that
there are many many wolves that are
following her around they're just
they're running around hunting I did a
video on this last year so I'll put a
link in the description but basically
Martin has said that he wouldn't create
a super pack if it wasn't gonna play in
later in the story so the super pack
sounds like it's gonna be something of a
nuclear weapon in the war for the dawn
or they could just be hunting down juicy
phrases and juicy Bolton's who knows but
they will be back next question dr. pug
ass what do you think about Howland Reed
in the show which storyline would he get
caught up in I would think the North
remembers storyline we haven't seen him
on the show yet like he hasn't appeared
so we have no idea who's gonna be
playing him but I do think that he'll be
on the show soon they are casting
northern Lords for season six I don't
know if we'll see him in season six we
might see me in season seven or eight
but he's way too big of a character in
the history of A Song of Ice and Fire to
not appear on the show in some way
just as a tangent though wouldn't it be
totally weird if they did him in a
flashback but not in present-day
cuz he's not dead like he's still alive
in present-day you know I do not think
that he is the high Sparrow next
question on Sat s what about Loras and
Margaery are they totally screwed with
the highest Sparrow thing no remember
when the high Sparrow was trying to get
Cersei to confess he said that Margaery
and Loras did and because of that they
probably looked upon favorably at the
trial they're not totally off the hook
or anything they still have to go to the
trial - but he made it sound like he
didn't really care about what they've
done they'd confess they'd serve some
small penance and they'd probably fine
next question galaxy s what about Aria's
dancing master so you're talking about
Syrio Forel so it hasn't been confirmed
that he died although they wanted you to
think that at the end of season five
they should have been the previously on
for the finale episode so it made it
seem like Arya was getting revenge for
his killing and even if they were vague
about it the actors that play Meryn
Trant and Syrio Forel
were kind of making fun of each other on
Twitter just a little bit just having a
little bit of fun like thanks for the
memories thanks for killing me hahaha
Maisie Williams even chimed in and was
like ladies please please calm down
ladies so the after the place here of
Pharrell thinks that he is dead then he
is probably dead but if you want to be
conspiracy nut you could totally believe
it but no I don't think that jaqen
H'ghar is Syrio Forel like I don't think
that someone else was secretly Syrio
Forel next question sum-sum asks do you
think that bran will be able to control
a dragon with his work abilities George
are Martin actually gets asked this all
the time and all he says is there's no
precedent for it like he just doesn't
want to spoil it I'm assuming but if you
look at it this way
the dragons are animals they're closer
to being lizards than they are to being
Birds but there's still animals so brand
should be able to work into them but I
think a lot of it has to do with how
powerful the mind is of the thing that
he's working into Martin hasn't really
explained it that well in the books I
think I think he's just saving a lot of
things for later but a lot of you asked
if he'd be able to war again to a white
Walker or something like that and all I
can say to that is is probably not just
because they have such powerful magic -
like it would probably be harder for
bran to war again - Melisandre than it
would be for Hodor or someone with a
very simple mind so if his skill level
gets a lot better and there's a dragon
in proximity to him like line-of-sight I
think I think he has to be a line of
sight then he could probably warg into
one next question braid
yes do you think that Brianne will catch
the Lady Stoneheart storyline I would
say if they decide to include those
elements in the story yeah definitely
but I think it'll be a different
character won't be the Lady Stoneheart
from the books somatically it just works
really well with the idea of the North
remembers in that that storyline that we
know that they're doing in season six
but one of the problems with what
happens with Bree and the books are is
that she's kind of left on a cliffhanger
like we don't we don't know what happens
to her so the show is plugging to take a
few liberties and continue with that
storyline just in my own opinion in the
books I think that she's fine I think
that she saved herself at the last
minute so I think that something similar
will happen on this show just Brienne of
Tarth
Gwendoline Christie such amazing
characters with an amazing actor that I
think it would be a huge mistake of the
show to get rid of her next question
make CEO 9 1 7 s do you think that we'll
get to see any new Valyrian steel forged
now that we have dragons out and about
I'm hoping this Sam will get his hands
on some secrets at the Citadel well he
would definitely be one of the
characters to figure out how to forge
Valyrian steel but we don't know if they
actually have those in the Citadel there
are really two places in the world that
have amazing libraries one is the
Citadel and the other is an acai where
Melisandre comes from it's way way over
here in the east the Far East that's
actually where Daenerys is dragon eggs
were purchased if you wonder where they
came from the coast over there is
pockmarked with caves so a lot of people
think that there are clutches of dragon
eggs I think I actually did a video
about that too so I'll put another link
in the description but it just implied
that part of the secret sauce of making
Valyrian steel is dragon fire if they're
gonna be fighting a war for the dawn
though they're gonna need an army with
tools that can defeat White Walkers in
Valyrian steel along with obsidian are
the only two things that we know about
that can do that there's also a theory
that obsidian could be involved in the
creation of Valyrian steel too in
Dragonstone is like an obsidian factory
because dragons lived there for so long
they call it dragon glass for a reason
so I'd really like to see Daenerys turn
dragon stone into a Valyrian steel
factory that would be amazing
next question Rondon says could we talk
about how tyrion and varys his goals
will play out in Game of Thrones
I believe they both have the best of
intentions but sometimes Varys makes me
wonder well if you remember when Varys
was trying to convince Tyrion to help
him he was talking about a higher
purpose like we need
to put someone on the throne that will
help us survive what is coming he hasn't
talked a whole lot about White Walkers
or the war for the dawn so he may or may
not have an idea of what's going on with
that we only know that he just wants
what he thinks is best for Westeros and
he thinks that Daenerys is the right
person for the job so he and Tyrion will
just do whatever it takes to put
Daenerys on the Iron Throne
that's their ultimate goal right now
obviously their short-term goal though
is taking care of marine while Daenerys
is away so I think most of their time in
season six is gonna be spent fighting
off the rest of slavers Bay that are
probably gonna try and move in now that
Daenerys is away if you guys have read
the sample chapters from wins a winner
just please use spoiler tags because
there is some talk of what's going on
with Tyrion and marine next question in
Nicola s hey Charlie which family and
Game of Thrones is the most interesting
and the books in the TV show well I mean
off the top of my head I would say House
Targaryen just because they go so far
back there's so much history there
George or Martin has said that like one
of his next projects after he's done
with the Song of Ice and Fire
is to do a complete history of the
Targaryen family like a story told from
their perspective it's supposedly going
to be called fire and blood the Starks
are really interesting too I mean I
really like to learn more about the
kings of winter those were all the stark
kings from the time of the first men to
the time of Aegon's conquest but
definitely Targaryen first because I
really want to see ancient Valyria
next question mesh gate asks do you
think that Rican Sansa will go to the
Iron Islands and that's how we'll catch
up to the Greyjoy's or they'll be an
entirely different story so I assume
you're asking mostly about the Iron
Islands I think that there'll be a
completely separate story Kingsmoot
things that happen in the books that
they've just skipped so far there's
actually been some reports today that
say that they've cast their euron
greyjoy and they've filmed some scenes
that will lead up to the Kingsmoot now
if you've read the books and you know
what happens to lead to the Kings boot
please just use spoiler tags if you're
going to talk about it because it seems
like that part of the Ironborn storyline
is just gonna be straight out of the
books but I'm not expecting reek and
Sansa to crossover with the Ironborn
storyline in a major way
I'm expecting their storyline to revolve
mostly around the North remembers and
the other northern Lords but thank you
so much for so many questions everyone
they're always a ton of fun to do
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner to see donike you win a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to message
me on the back end of my channel so I
get your contact info let me know what
you guys want me to do for my next game
of Thrones bonus video but there's
actually a bunch of huge stuff happening
in the next couple of days there's Star
Wars Force Friday which I'm thinking of
is like Disney's Kickstarter for their
Star Wars Expanded Universe like they're
raising money by selling toys and doing
unboxing online look at how poor we are
we won't be able to make 10 more Star
Wars films unless you buy billions of
dollars worth of toys this is a bunch of
flash news there's some Green Lantern
arrow news so I'll be doing those videos
next and there should be a couple
trailers for that stuff coming soon too
but while you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn all about the super
pack under direwolves and you can click
here to learn all about ash I thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you